hey guys it's justine and today we have
something very fun to unbox
these are some brand new headphones from
a new company called nothing
now this is carl pays new endeavor and i
love the whole concept behind the brand
because they want it to feel like
technology is sort of integrated into
your life where it's invisible like it's
nothing it's there but it's not if that
makes any sense but i'm very excited to
open these up because first of all
the box the packaging like everything
about it
looks really really cool we're also
gonna be doing a giveaway of some of
these exclusive ones that will be
ijustine edition so basically it'll have
like a little inscription that says that
these are issued by me
to you so i'm gonna be holding that on
twitter and instagram so basically
follow me and nothing on instagram and
twitter and leave us comments if you
guys would like to win a pair
let's just open these up because i have
been looking at these
all day so i can't wait to open it so
here's the box
so this is kind of like their first
product launch so there's going to be
more products in the future but this is
what they're starting with there's our
little pool tab
oh it's like a box inside of a box
i'm shook this is like a really pretty
box like it's all
silver freaking fancy hello it's been a
while since i've been like really
excited
about a product launch and i just really
love everything that carl has done
previously so it's really cool to see
him kind of on this new adventure
are you ready let's do it oh
hello oh this looks so like like this
just looks super mysterious
come on out little cake look this is
fancy
look at that check this case out
i like that everything is really clear
and transparent so you can actually like
see the inner workings of these earbuds
let's see if there's anything else in
here
oh yeah we've got we've got more things
guys i'm actually keeping this box to
put stuff in like i don't know what i'm
gonna put in here but this is a really
cool box definitely keeping that
look at this oh it's our little quick
start guide i love this font
too super cool oh we gotta get the app a
little welcome
fast pairing android only okay we've got
our earbuds
so some extras here we have some small
and large extra earbud
options which must mean that medium
comes pre-installed and we have our
cable here
oh even the cable is nice it's like a
transparent kind of like clear little
like plasticky silicone feel that that's
nice
i love a short usbc cable like this is
this is nice
very nice all right let's open these up
for the first time
this case actually can be charged
wirelessly which is really cool but of
course if you want to do a faster charge
you would want to use the usbc cable
look at this this looks good
that looks nice i freaking love the look
of these
let's open them up oh check that out
there's like a little light right there
too
i don't know why i'm whispering i feel
like i have to be quiet for some reason
i feel like their attention to detail is
also
something to be noted so it's really
cool because they have
two little dots on each side of these
so the red one is for your right ear and
the white one is for your left
i'm always so nervous when it comes to
headphones because i have such
a struggle of getting them to stay in my
ear so if these stay in my ear it's
gonna be a freaking miracle and i'm
gonna be
so happy so i i love the feel already
like this is actually quite nice
look shake shake shake shake shake these
don't fall out of my head
oh i got dizzy uh so far so good so i do
have the mediums on right now
the smile test so when i smile usually
headphones
pop right out of my ear look at this i'm
smiling
i'm smiling and shaking my head
i'm really excited now so with the
charging case i'm talking louder because
these are now
blocking the sound in my ear so you can
see the little charging
connectors right there on each side i
love that the case also has the little
red dot there so there'll be no
confusion
as to where to place your earbud right
on there just like so
let's get these all paired up to that
allow scanning and there you are buddy
there you are let's connect meet okay
let's meet you
double tap triple tap tap and hold so
this gives you your battery levels
it has three modes it's got the noise
cancellation the maximum the light
and the transparency mode and then this
also shows you
the touch control options okay there's a
new
firmware update available let's do our
update
and then listen to some tunes
[Music]
so just let that happen i'm gonna go
have a snack
you might be able to hear me chewing i'm
having a banana
oh wow i did so many things all right
they are all set up everything is
updated
[Music]
so i've got them all set up but i
thought i should probably take them out
to really test
the noise cancellation so i love that
the stems of these
are really flat which makes gesture
control very very easy
so far i have been loving the fact that
you can adjust the volume
so you just kind of swipe up and down to
adjust volume
double tap to play triple tap to switch
songs and if you tap and hold this is
how you can change
the noise cancellation options it's
great because they do have a few
different modes they have light
maximum and then they have a
transparency and then if you want to
turn all of that off
you can easily just switch that off i'm
afraid
am i talking too loud i don't know
because i can't hear myself talking
right now
so i just dropped one of my earbuds and
this actually has a feature called find
my earbud so it'll make a noise
to help me find it
oh oh hold on a second here it is
well thank you guys so much for watching
i'm so glad i could give you guys a
first look at these new nothing earbuds
they are awesome i
absolutely love the case and the fact
that these are only 99 with an
incredible case
great battery life and they look amazing
like i said the beginning of the video i
am partnered with nothing to do a
giveaway i'll put a link in the
description where you can find all of
the information i'm so excited for you
guys to get a pair of these and check
them out
until then don't forget to like comment
and subscribe on this video and be sure
to hit the bell so you'll be notified
when i post new videos check the link in
the description for
all of the information about the
giveaway i'll see you guys later bye
good luck
you